You may remember this story that we did about a year ago, about canvassers going door to door and talking to voters for 20 minutes. And in just 20 minutes, the canvassers got some voters to change their minds, to flip positions on big, hot button issues. Gay marriage. Abortion.
你可能还记得我们大约在一年前做的那个报道，关于拉票员挨家挨户走访并与选民交谈20分钟的事。仅仅20分钟，拉票员就让一些选民改变了想法，在同性婚姻、堕胎等重大热点议题上转变了立场。
Which, of course, is amazing, right? That is not something that seems like it's even possible. There was a study in a well-known, peer reviewed journal-- Science magazine-- proving how remarkably effective these people were. They invented a whole new way to sway voter opinion. It seemed like a game changer, a whole new tool for politics, for liberals or conservatives to use.
这当然很神奇，对吧？这看起来甚至是不可能的事。在一份著名的同行评审期刊——《科学》杂志——上有一项研究，证明了这些人是多么显著地有效。他们发明了一种全新的方法来左右选民的观点。这看起来像是一个改变游戏规则的东西，是自由派或保守派可以使用的全新政治工具。
And then a month after our radio story-- maybe you saw this in the news-- there was overwhelming evidence that one of the researchers, a grad student named Michael LaCour had fabricated all the data. Science magazine retracted the article.
就在我们的广播报道播出一个月后——也许你在新闻里看到了——有压倒性的证据表明，其中一位研究人员，一名叫迈克尔·拉库尔的研究生，伪造了所有数据。《科学》杂志撤回了这篇文章。
But the team that invented this canvassing technique, they were not the ones that did the research study. That was a separate thing. And they were just as shocked as anybody. Maybe more shocked.
但是，发明这种拉票技术的团队并不是做这项研究的人。那是另一码事。他们和任何人一样感到震惊。也许更震惊。
The week the news broke, one of the canvass organizers, Steve DeLine, told me they'd spent months meticulously going door to door and keeping perfect records of everything they were doing for this researcher. To find out that LaCour had just made up his part of the data--
新闻曝光的那一周，拉票组织者之一史蒂夫·德莱恩告诉我，他们花了几个月时间一丝不苟地挨家挨户走访，并为这位研究人员记录了他们所做的一切。得知拉库尔只是编造了他那部分数据——
It's unfathomable to me, having you know, made sure that we were dotting every I and crossing every T. And you know, jumping through every hoop that he asked of us. It's just-- just can't really explain it. I'm at a loss.
这让我无法理解，你知道的，我们确保了所有细节都一丝不苟，完成了他要求的每一个环节。这真的……真的没法解释。我感到不知所措。
Then in August, three months after the retraction, four months after our story aired--
然后在八月，撤稿三个月后，我们的报道播出四个月后——
Hi.
嗨。
Steve.
史蒂夫。
Dave.
戴夫。
Hi.
嗨。
Nice to meet you.
很高兴见到你。
Nice to meet you guys in person.
很高兴亲自见到你们。
We got a visitor to our office from two of the guys who'd developed this canvassing technique, that guy Steve and his coworker Dave Fleischer. They happened to be in town from California. And they had news.
我们办公室来了一位访客，是开发这种拉票技术的两个人之一，那个叫史蒂夫的家伙和他的同事戴夫·弗莱彻。他们正好从加州来城里。他们带来了消息。
A brand new study with new researchers was looking into their work. Results were coming in. Here's Dave.
一项由新研究人员进行的全新研究正在审视他们的工作。结果正在汇总。这是戴夫。
We're not anticipating going public with these results until January at the earliest, and maybe not till June.
我们预计至少要到一月才会公布这些结果，也许要到六月。
What these researchers really wanted to do was publish their results in Science magazine, you know, the place that published the original, discredited study. In fact, one of the researchers was laying the groundwork for that.
这些研究人员真正想做的是在《科学》杂志上发表他们的结果，你知道的，那个刊登了最初那项被抹黑研究的地方。事实上，其中一位研究人员正在为此打基础。
So he actually called up Marcia McNutt, who's the editor of Science. And they didn't immediately reject it out of hand. She just said, "You know, the bar's going to be very high." [LAUGHS] Well, no [BEEP] fooling.
所以他真的给《科学》杂志的编辑玛西娅·麦克纳特打了电话。他们并没有立即断然拒绝。她只是说：“你知道，门槛会非常高。”（笑）好吧，毫无疑问。
Well, apparently Science magazine liked what the new researchers did. This week they published the new study about these canvassers.
好吧，显然《科学》杂志喜欢这些新研究人员所做的工作。本周他们发表了关于这些拉票员的新研究。
This one's not fake. We know now, for real, whether those canvassers are, in fact, convincing anyone of anything when they go door to door. And if anything, what the canvassers are achieving and the way that they're achieving it is even more interesting than the fake study said.
这篇不是假的。我们现在确实知道，这些拉票员挨家挨户走访时是否真的说服了任何人。而且如果说有什么的话，拉票员所取得的成就以及他们取得成就的方式，甚至比那项假研究说的还要有趣。
From WBEZ Chicago and This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, "For Your Reconsideration." We have this story and two other stories where people go back and revisit evidence from the past. And just to start this off, in case you didn't hear our first story about those canvassers a year ago, here's what they were. If you heard that show, this will just be a quick reminder.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是“重新考虑”。我们有这个故事以及另外两个人们回顾过去证据的故事。首先，以防你没有听我们一年前关于那些拉票员的第一篇报道，这里是背景介绍。如果你听过那期节目，这只是一个简短的提醒。
Hi. We're talking to registered voters in your neighborhood today about their views on abortion.
嗨。我们今天正在与你们社区的登记选民谈论他们对堕胎的看法。
This is one of the canvassers. She's young, with tattoos and a halter top. It's a warm Los Angeles day, and the voter's on the other side of a screen door. She's older, heavyset, wire rimmed glasses. She's a nurse.
这是一位拉票员。她很年轻，有纹身，穿着挂脖上衣。这是洛杉矶温暖的一天，选民站在纱门后面。她年纪较大，身材魁梧，戴着细框眼镜。她是一名护士。
And OK, just to be clear, what you're about to hear is a real canvasser with a real voter. This is not part of the discredited study. This is from a video of one of the regular canvasses these guys Dave and Steve organized. The canvasser begins by asking this voter what she believes about abortion on a scale from zero to 10.
好的，为了明确起见，你接下来要听到的是一位真正的拉票员与一位真正的选民的对话。这不是那项欺诈性研究的一部分。这是来自戴夫和史蒂夫组织的常规拉票活动视频。拉票员首先询问这位选民在0到10的范围内对堕胎的看法。
Zero means you think women should have no access to abortion. 10 means women should have full access to abortion.
0意味着你认为女性不应有堕胎权。10意味着女性应拥有完全的堕胎权。
The voter says zero. No access. No abortions for anybody. She's Catholic, from Mexico.
选民说0。没有堕胎权。任何人都不能堕胎。她是天主教徒，来自墨西哥。
And they start talking about how hard it can be to discuss abortion. Even with family.
他们开始谈论讨论堕胎有多困难。即使是和家人。
How did that feel for you to talk to your daughters?
和你的女儿们谈论这件事对你来说感觉如何？
It's not easy. It's not easy, because in my country they have taboos, a lot of taboos. And my mother is one of the person never talking about sexual relations or conceptions.
不容易。不容易，因为在我的国家有很多禁忌。我母亲是一个从不谈论性关系或受孕话题的人。
Yeah.
是的。
That's why I try to be very open with my daughters.
这就是为什么我尽量对我的女儿们保持开放态度。
Notice that this conversation's just begun and already she's talking about her daughters and her mom. That's no accident. This whole technique is built around having a very personal conversation, a very real conversation about the voter's experiences. To make that happen, this canvasser does something that a lot of the canvassers do-- she talks about her own experiences.
注意到谈话才刚开始，她就已经在谈论她的女儿和母亲了。这不是偶然。整个技术建立在进行非常个人化、非常真实的对话，讨论选民经历的基础上。为了实现这一点，这位拉票员做了许多拉票员都会做的事——谈论她自己的经历。
My mother's from the Philippines.
我母亲来自菲律宾。
Uh-huh.
嗯。
And my mother went through the same thing. Like, it's not something that you talk about.
我母亲也经历了同样的事情。就像，这不是你可以谈论的事情。
No. It's not.
不。确实不是。
Huh.
哈。
In my family, it's the same.
在我家里，情况也一样。
When I got my period, I was 12 years old.
我来月经的时候，我才12岁。
Mhm.
嗯。
And--
而且——
The voter tells her that when she was 11 and got her period, nobody explained what was happening. She thought she was dying.
选民告诉她，她11岁来月经时，没人解释发生了什么。她以为自己要死了。
And I believe I am dying. [LAUGHS]
我以为我要死了。（笑）
Oh! [LAUGHS]
噢！（笑）
And when she was six, her mom miscarried a baby. But nobody explained what was going on to her. And so she's tried to be different with her daughters and talk to them. That's why she became a nurse, she says, to help women.
当她六岁时，她妈妈流产了。但没人向她解释发生了什么。所以她尽量以不同的方式对待她的女儿并与她们交谈。她说这就是她成为护士的原因，为了帮助女性。
So these two strangers are swapping stories and really talking from the heart. And 15 minutes into this 22-minute conversation, the canvasser circles back to the subject at hand in a very pointed way.
所以这两个陌生人在交换故事，真心实意地交流。在这场22分钟对话的第15分钟，拉票员以一种非常直接的方式回到了手头的话题。
I had an abortion.
我做过堕胎手术。
Mhm.
嗯。
In November this past year.
就在去年十一月。
Oh, I'm so sorry.
噢，我很抱歉。
And it wasn't the wrong choice for me.
对我来说，这不是错误的选择。
Mhm.
嗯。
Because that's what felt right for me. But I was alone.
因为那是我觉得正确的做法。但我一个人。
Yeah.
是的。
And it was scary.
而且很可怕。
Uh-huh.
嗯。
And it wasn't-- it was because I don't know how to talk about it with people. Like, my family, my mother loves me. And so does my papa and my sister.
因为我不知道如何与别人谈论它。比如，我的家人，我妈妈爱我。我爸爸和妹妹也一样。
Mhm.
嗯。
But--
但是——
I know, but it's hard. And you carry it for the rest of your life. It's your decision--
我知道，但这很难。你得带着它过一辈子。这是你的决定——
Yeah.
是的。
But you carry it for the rest of your life.
但你得带着它过一辈子。
If you are-- one of the things that I struggled with with telling my family is this idea that my family's going to love me less.
如果你——我告诉家人时挣扎的事情之一就是这种想法，即我的家人会不再爱我。
No. Never.
不。绝不会。
Would you ever love your daughters less?
你会少爱你的女儿们吗？
No. Never.
不。绝不会。
It's a moment that's simultaneously intimate and manipulative and honest all at once. And it works.
这是一个同时具有亲密性、操纵性和诚实性的时刻。而且它奏效了。
After this, the canvasser asks the voter again to rate on a scale of zero to 10 where she stands on access to abortion. Remember, she was a zero before.
之后，拉票员再次要求选民在0到10的范围内评估她对堕胎权的立场。记住，她之前是0。
We have that same zero to 10 scale where zero means no access and 10 means full access.
我们有同样的0到10量表，其中0意味着没有堕胎权，10意味着完全的堕胎权。
10.
10。
A 10?
10？
Mhm.
嗯。
She's been standing at the door just 18 minutes. So again, OK, that's real. That is not part of the fraudulent study.
她在门口才站了18分钟。所以，好吧，那是真实的。那不是欺诈性研究的一部分。
The team that invented this technique of going door to door-- including Dave Fleischer and Steve Deline, the two guys who visited our office at the beginning of this story-- they work at the Los Angeles LGBT Center, which is a big, multimillion-dollar nonprofit, the biggest LGBT organization in the world. They started doing these canvasses in 2009. They were hoping to change voters' minds to support gay marriage. This was in the wake of Proposition 8, which rejected gay marriage in California.
发明这种挨家挨户拉票技术的团队——包括戴夫·弗莱彻和史蒂夫·德莱恩，也就是故事开头访问我们办公室的那两个人——他们在洛杉矶LGBT中心工作，这是一个大型的、价值数百万美元的非营利组织，是世界上最大的LGBT组织。他们从2009年开始进行这些拉票活动。他们希望改变选民的想法，以支持同性婚姻。这是在加州第8号提案（拒绝同性婚姻）之后发生的。
And they discovered through trial and error that the trick to this whole thing was they don't try to reason with people about rights and equality and big principles like that. Canvass organizer Steve Deline says if you're talking at a kind of rational, sort of intellectual level about things, you're gonna fail.
他们通过试错发现，整个事情的秘诀在于，他们不尝试在权利、平等和类似的大原则上与人们讲理。拉票组织者史蒂夫·德莱恩说，如果你在谈论理性、知识层面的东西，你注定会失败。
That's not where people make their decisions about issues like this. People make their decisions about how they're going to vote on this at a gut level and at a visceral level and an emotional level.
人们不是在那里对这样的议题做出决定的。人们在直觉、本能和情感层面上决定如何投票。
This is what they learned-- to stop telling people things. The most important thing the canvasser should do is listen.
这就是他们学到的——停止告诉人们事情。拉票员应该做的最重要的事情是倾听。
I think the big revelation was that our job was actually to go and give them the chance to talk about their own life, and realize that you know, maybe that led them to conclusions that were a little different than they'd thought.
我认为最大的启示是，我们的工作实际上是去给他们机会谈论自己的生活，并意识到，也许这使他们得出了与他们原先想法略有不同的结论。
So they're out doing this, trying their canvasses. And it took them less than a year to start to get decent results like you heard with that nurse. A small but noticeable number of people at the door told them that their minds had been changed.
所以他们出去做这件事，尝试他们的拉票活动。不到一年，他们就开始获得像你从那位护士身上听到的那样不错的结果。门口一小部分但显眼的人告诉他们，他们的想法被改变了。
But of course, the only way to tell for sure if their minds changed and stayed changed was to have outsiders-- scientists-- do a proper case control study. And that's why the canvassers invited in two political scientists to do the original study that was published in Science magazine. That grad student from UCLA-- Michael LaCour-- did the actual research. But the study design and results were overseen by a big deal political scientist from Columbia University named Donald Green, who's kind of legendary in that world for transforming how people do field experiments. And Green says that before they started, he expected the results were going to show--
当然，确定他们的想法是否改变并持续改变的唯一方法，是让局外人——科学家——进行适当的对照研究。这就是为什么拉票员邀请了两位政治学家来进行最初发表在《科学》杂志上的研究。那位加州大学洛杉矶分校的研究生——迈克尔·拉库尔——进行了实际研究。但研究设计和结果由哥伦比亚大学一位大人物政治学家唐纳德·格林监督，他在那个领域因彻底改变人们进行实地实验的方式而具有传奇色彩。格林说，在他们开始之前，他预计结果会显示——
Short-term effects. I thought that those effects would subside in a few days' time.
短期效应。我以为这些效应会在几天内消退。
He thought that 'cause pretty much that's what always happens. People change their minds and then the effect wears off. Or much more common, they don't change their minds at all.
他那样想是因为这几乎总是发生的情况。人们改变主意，然后效果就消失了。或者更常见的是，他们根本不会改变主意。
There's a hefty body of research documenting something called the backfire effect, which happens with most of us. When we're confronted with evidence disproving something that we personally believe, most of us generally just dig in, and we believe it more.
有大量的研究记录了一种被称为“逆火效应”的现象，这发生在我们大多数人身上。当我们面对反驳我们个人信仰的证据时，我们大多数人通常只是更加固执，我们更加相信它。
This is a phenomenon, by the way, that's familiar to anybody who's ever been to a Thanksgiving dinner during an election year and tried to argue with some favorite uncle's wrongheaded political opinions. Never works, right? Facts mean nothing. And by the way, Uncle Lenny, I am not talking about you.
顺便说一句，这种现象对于任何在选举年参加感恩节晚餐并试图与某个最喜爱的叔叔争论其错误政治观点的人来说都很熟悉。从来没用，对吧？事实毫无意义。顺便说一句，莱尼叔叔，我说的不是你。
But this is what was so revolutionary about the data that this grad student seemed to be gathering about these canvassers. He said he did online surveys with the voters who got visited by the canvassers and they showed that their minds changed and stayed changed for six months, nine months, a year after the canvasser knocked at the door.
但这正是那个研究生似乎正在收集的关于这些拉票员的数据所具有的革命性意义。他说他对被拉票员访问过的选民进行了在线调查，结果显示他们的想法改变了，并且在拉票员敲门后的六个月、九个月、一年里一直保持改变。
Green told me that he and his colleagues had read through over 900 papers, never seen anything like this result, to change people's opinions and have it last like this. Though interestingly, when LaCour first showed his data to Professor Green, Green thought, this data is so perfect, these results might be real. But OK, best to be sure.
格林告诉我，他和他的同事们阅读了900多篇论文，从未见过像这样的结果，即改变人们的观点并使之持续这么久。尽管有趣的是，当拉库尔第一次向格林教授展示他的数据时，格林认为，这些数据太完美了，这些结果可能是真的。但好的，最好确定一下。
And he told LaCour to do the entire study-- canvasses, surveys, everything-- a second time. Which LaCour did. Same result.
他告诉拉库尔把整个研究——拉票、调查、一切——再做一遍。拉库尔照做了。结果一样。
Now, of course, later, Green's suspicions would be confirmed in spades. All that data would be shown to be fraudulent. But here's what LaCour said he found in the original study published in Science .
当然，后来格林的怀疑被彻底证实了。所有这些数据都被证明是伪造的。但这是拉库尔在发表于《科学》杂志的原始研究中声称的发现。
OK, so what I'm about to say is from the discredited results of a retracted study. This study was about gay marriage. It was about convincing people to support gay marriage. And the study claimed that a year after the canvassers visited voters' homes, the number of voters supporting gay marriage had jumped 15%. 15%.
好了，我接下来要说的来自于一项被撤回的、被抹黑的研究结果。这项研究是关于同性婚姻的。它是关于说服人们支持同性婚姻。研究声称，在拉票员访问选民家庭一年后，支持同性婚姻的选民人数跃升了15%。15%。
But-- and this was key-- according to the study, the 15% increase only happened if the canvasser at the door had been gay and admitted being gay to the voter. People who talked to other canvassers only rose 3%, which is about as much as the nation as a whole changed on the issue of gay marriage that year.
但是——这是关键——根据这项研究，只有当门口的拉票员是同性恋并向选民承认自己是同性恋时，15%的增长才会发生。与非同性恋拉票员交谈的人数仅上升了3%，这大约与那一年全美在同性婚姻议题上的变化程度相当。
It was a similar effect with abortion, according LaCour. He said the number of people who became pro-choice after the canvass rose 5%. And again, the effect only lasted if the canvasser at the door revealed that she had had an abortion. It was talking to somebody affected by the issue that seemed to be changing people's minds.
根据拉库尔的研究，堕胎方面也有类似的效果。他说，拉票后变成支持堕胎的人数上升了5%。同样，只有当门口的拉票员透露她曾经堕胎过，效果才会持续。似乎是与受此议题影响的人交谈改变了人们的想法。
I actually interviewed Michael LaCour a year ago for the story that I did for our show about all this. I have to say, it's strange listening to that interview today, knowing what happened just a few weeks after we talked, that his data would be shown to be fraudulent. 'Cause when I talked to him, he really talked like somebody doing a real study with real surveys. Like for instance, I asked him how attitudes towards abortion changed over time among the voters that he was studying.
我实际上在一年前就我为我们的节目所做的关于这一切的报道采访了迈克尔·拉库尔。我必须说，今天听那次采访感觉很奇怪，因为我知道在我们谈话几周后发生的事情，他的数据被证明是欺诈性的。因为当我与他交谈时，他真的像是一个正在进行真实研究、有着真实调查的人。例如，我问他选民对堕胎的态度是如何随时间变化的。
So that's still ongoing. Because I'm tracking longitudinally these individuals over a course. I don't want to give out a hard number, but it stays relatively flat. And I think it levels off around five percentage points. That's around 200 days later.
那还在进行中。因为我正在对这些个体进行纵向追踪。我不想给出一个确切的数字，但它保持相对平稳。我认为在大约200天后趋于平稳，大约在5个百分点左右。
He offered conclusions from his data. Like this one.
他从他的数据中得出了结论。比如这个。
So one of the things is people change their-- when they had contact with a gay person discussing gay equality-- they changed their minds, not just about the policy issue about same sex marriage. They also changed their minds about gay people, gays and lesbians as a group.
所以其中一点是人们改变了他们的——当他们与一位讨论同性恋平权的同性恋者接触时——他们改变了想法，不仅是关于同性婚姻的政策议题。他们也改变了对同性恋者、作为一个群体的男同性恋和女同性恋的看法。
Nice if that were true. If there were data supporting it.
如果那是真的就好了。如果有支持它的数据的话。
Or there was this finding, which is so particular and specific that again, if there is no data supporting this, it's just a very idiosyncratic thing to decide to say is true. LaCour said that he graded each gay canvasser on how stereotypically gay they appeared. And--
或者有这样一个发现，它是如此具体和特殊，以至于再次重申，如果没有支持它的数据，决定说它是真的只是一件非常独特的事情。拉库尔说他给每位同性恋拉票员打分，看他们看起来有多么刻板的同性恋倾向。而且——
The gay canvassers who are perceived as straight had the largest effects.
那些被认为看起来像异性恋的同性恋拉票员产生了最大的影响。
That is, they were able to convince the most voters to support gay marriage.
也就是说，他们能够说服最多的选民支持同性婚姻。
So this suggests that voters may ordinarily have an unflattering mental image of a stereotypical gay person. And the discrepancy between the stereotype and the person standing on the doorstep creates a space for attitude change.
这表明，选民通常可能对典型的同性恋者有不太讨喜的心理形象。而刻板印象与站在门口的人之间的差异为态度的改变创造了空间。
Right. I see.
对。我明白了。
Especially when the canvassers are building empathy through respectful two-way conversation.
特别是当拉票员通过尊重的双向谈话建立共鸣时。
This vision of the world is such a hopeful vision of how the world might work. The world LaCour fabricated is one where intolerant people hold inaccurate stereotypes in their heads and all it takes is an empathetic conversation, one sincere talk, 20 minutes long, with somebody from the stereotyped group and the scales fall from their eyes. They realize they were wrong all along.
这种世界观是对世界如何运作的一种充满希望的愿景。拉库尔捏造的世界是一个不宽容的人脑中持有不准确的刻板印象，而只需要一次充满同理心的谈话，一次诚恳的对话，20分钟长，与来自刻板印象群体的人交谈，鳞片就会从他们眼中掉落。他们意识到自己一直都错了。
I like that world. I wish I lived in that world. Maybe we do live in that world for all we know. But if we do, there's no data proving it.
我喜欢那个世界。我希望我住在那个世界。也许我们确实住在那个世界，据我们所知。但如果我们确实住在那里，没有数据证明它。
[PHONE RINGING]
（电话铃声）
Hello?
喂？
Hey, Don Green?
嘿，唐·格林吗？
Yes.
是的。
Ira Glass.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Hey, Ira.
嘿，艾拉。
Last May, a month after we ran our story about LaCour's study, six months after he published that study in Science magazine, I called his co-author, Columbia professor Donald Green. Green had just reconsidered what was going on in the data LaCour had collected and had asked Science to retract their article, which the magazine did. He seemed understandably sobered and sad.
去年五月，在我们播出关于拉库尔研究的报道一个月后，也就是他在《科学》杂志发表该研究六个月后，我给他的合著者、哥伦比亚大学教授唐纳德·格林打了电话。格林刚刚重新审视了拉库尔收集的数据中发生的事情，并要求《科学》杂志撤回他们的文章，该杂志照做了。他看起来可以理解地变得冷静而悲伤。
It was such a waste. Not just of my time, obviously, but no, the Center and the canvassers' time.
这真是浪费。不仅浪费了我的时间，显然，更浪费了中心和拉票员的时间。
Yeah.
是的。
It's just crazy.
这太疯狂了。
The way the fraud was discovered was actually a little detective story of its own. A detective story that began kind of exactly the way they tell you in school that the scientific method is supposed to work.
发现欺诈的方式实际上本身就是一个小侦探故事。一个侦探故事，开始的方式和学校里教你的科学方法应该运作的方式几乎一模一样。
Two young researchers-- David Broockman and Joshua Kalla, both in their 20s-- tried to replicate what LaCour did. The  team from the Los Angeles LGBT Center and a Miami LGBT group was organizing a new canvass operation in Miami. Broockman and Kalla would study that.
两名年轻的研究人员——戴维·布鲁克曼和约书亚·卡拉，都才20多岁——试图复制拉库尔所做的事情。洛杉矶LGBT中心的团队和一个迈阿密的LGBT组织正在迈阿密组织一项新的拉票行动。布鲁克曼和卡拉将研究这一点。
Broockman was already suspicious of LaCour's data. It seemed too perfect. Then they started their research and they noticed something funny.
布鲁克曼已经对拉库尔的数据产生了怀疑。它看起来太完美了。然后他们开始研究，发现了一些奇怪的事情。
The way this experiment works, like I said, the researchers do online surveys of the voters' opinions before and after the canvassers come to their doors and talk to them. And the researchers pay the voters to fill out those online surveys to motivate them to do the surveys. And tons of voters filled out LaCour's surveys, but not Broockman and Kalla's.
正如我所说，这个实验的运作方式是，研究人员在拉票员来到选民门口并与他们交谈前后，对选民的观点进行在线调查。研究人员付费给选民以完成这些在线调查，从而激励他们参与。大量的选民完成了拉库尔的调查，但没有完成布鲁克曼和卡拉的调查。
This made no sense at all. And they didn't know what to do. If people didn't fill out their surveys, they'd have no study. They started to panic.
这完全没有道理。他们不知道该怎么办。如果人们不完成他们的调查，他们就不会有研究。他们开始恐慌。
So they reached out to the survey company that LaCour said he used to find out exactly how LaCour got so many people to fill in their surveys. The company informed them that LaCour was not one of their clients, that the employee LaCour said he worked with did not exist, and in fact, this company did not have the capability to do the things LaCour said they did for him.
所以他们联系了拉库尔声称使用的调查公司，以查清拉库尔到底是如何让那么多人完成他的调查的。该公司通知他们，拉库尔不是他们的客户，拉库尔声称与他合作的员工根本不存在，事实上，这家公司也没有能力做拉库尔声称他们为他做的事情。
The hundreds of thousands of dollars that was supposedly paid out to survey responders, which LaCour said came from funders like the Ford Foundation-- who LaCour thanked in his study-- never was actually granted to LaCour. Given all that, it was hard to see how any of the data could be real.
据称支付给调查受访者的数十万美元，拉库尔说这来自福特基金会等资助者——拉库尔在研究中感谢了他们——实际上从未拨给拉库尔。鉴于这一切，很难看出任何数据可能是真实的。
But LaCour held firm. Said the data was real. He even wrote a paper defending it. But he said that he could not show the data to anybody because he had destroyed all the original surveys to protect the privacy of the respondents.
但拉库尔坚持己见。说数据是真实的。他甚至写了一篇论文为之辩护。但他说他不能向任何人展示数据，因为他为了保护受访者的隐私，销毁了所有原始调查。
I'm not sure anybody believed him. He'd been headed for a prestigious job at Princeton University after finishing his doctoral thesis. Now that job evaporated. His collaborator Don Green says the odd thing was the fakery went way beyond what seemed to be necessary.
我不确定是否有人相信他。他在完成博士论文后原本要前往普林斯顿大学担任一份令人羡慕的工作。现在那份工作化为乌有了。他的合作者唐·格林说，奇怪的是，造假程度远远超过了似乎必要的范围。
And this was, I think, the thing that I just want to convey somehow, is that there was an incredible mountain of fabrication. It was the most baroque and ornate ornamentation.
我认为我想传达的一件事是，这里有一座令人难以置信的造假大山。它是最巴洛克和华丽的装饰。
There were stories. There were anecdotes. My Dropbox is filled with graphs and charts.
有故事。有轶事。我的Dropbox里装满了图表。
What do you mean there's stories and anecdotes? I thought the only thing that was fabricated was the online surveys?
你说的故事和轶事是什么意思？我以为唯一被捏造的是在线调查？
Right. But there would be stories out of the survey. So he would say things like, "well did you know that some of the people in the survey came out?"
没错。但调查中会有故事。所以他会说诸如，“嗯，你知道调查中的一些人出柜了吗？”
As if, in later surveys, their attitudes about homosexuality had changed enough that they were comfortable finally admitting to the surveyors that they were gay. Except of course, the surveys didn't seem to exist.
好像在后来的调查中，他们对同性恋的态度发生了足够的改变，以至于他们终于觉得舒服到向调查员承认自己是同性恋了。除了当然，这些调查似乎并不存在。
It's layer after layer of embellishment that the sheer magnitude of it makes it very hard to entertain the possibility that it's all made up.
这是一层又一层的装饰，其巨大的规模使得很难相信这完全是捏造的。
The day after the truth came to light, one of the guys who created the canvasses, Dave Fleischer, told me that that's what he found himself trying to get his head around, the layers of embellishment. He told me this story about working with Michael LaCour.
真相大白后的第二天，创造这些拉票活动的其中一人，戴夫·弗莱彻，告诉我，这正是他发现自己试图理解的事情，那些装饰的层面。他告诉我这个关于与迈克尔·拉库尔合作的故事。
At our very first canvass where Mike was measuring us, right, we were running the canvass training, we're sending people out canvassing, we're going out canvassing. And Mike has a laptop set up. And as voters that we've talked to then fill out their first post-canvassing survey--
在我们迈克测量我们的第一次拉票活动中，对吧，我们正在进行拉票培训，我们在派人出去拉票，我们自己也在拉票。迈克设置了一台笔记本电脑。当我们需要交谈的选民填写他们第一次拉票后的调查时——
In other words, after real life canvassers came to their doors, Michael LaCour is supposedly having these voters fill out online surveys. And he's telling the canvassers, those surveys--
换句话说，在现实生活中的拉票员来到他们家门口后，迈克尔·拉库尔据称让这些选民填写在线调查。他告诉拉票员，那些调查——
Some of them are starting to trickle in. And Mike's got his laptop set up with him gazing intently at it. And his group of about a half dozen research assistants clustered around him gazing at it raptly, the way you would at election results on a presidential election night.
其中一些开始陆续进来了。迈克全神贯注地盯着他的笔记本电脑。他的一组大约六名研究助理聚集在他周围，专注地盯着它，就像你在总统选举之夜看着选举结果那样。
And after we finished the canvass de-brief and the volunteers leave, Mike invites us-- the team of staff organizers-- to come over and also glimpse the findings that are starting to emerge. And I really have thought back on this moment obviously, in the last 24 hours. Because it really looked like, oh my god, the results are coming in.
在我们结束拉票汇报并且志愿者离开后，迈克邀请我们——工作人员团队——过去一瞥开始显现的调查结果。显然，我在过去24小时里真的回想起了这一刻。因为它看起来真的很像，天哪，结果出来了。
Wait, wait, wait. And so what was on his screen? Did you see his screen?
等等，等等。那么他的屏幕上是什么？你看到他的屏幕了吗？
Oh yeah. It was like a-- heck, it's like data points coming in. And he would go back and forth between these two-- it's probably an old fashioned term from when I studied sociology-- but scattergrams.
哦，是的。就像……天哪，就像数据点进来了。他会在两者之间来回切换——这可能是一个我学习社会学时的老派术语——但散点图。
These are like charts.
这些就像图表。
Yes. There's a graphic depiction.
是的。有一个图形化的描绘。
And so he's going back and forth. And are those charts changing over the course of the time you look at them?
所以他在来回切换。而且那些图表在你看着它们的过程中是在变化的吗？
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
It's so elaborate.
太复杂了。
Well, yes. It would have been a whole lot easier just to have measured our work.
嗯，是的。如果只是衡量我们的工作会容易得多。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
How do you explain this? Like, you worked with him for many, many hours. How are you putting this together in your head?
你怎么解释这个？你和他共事了许多许多小时。你在脑海里是怎么把这些拼凑起来的？
Two years, Ira. And yeah, it is not really understandable to me. Because you spoke, I believe, with Mike on the phone.
两年，艾拉。是的，这对我来说真的无法理解。因为我相信你和迈克通过电话。
Yeah.
是的。
And he's a smart guy. He, I think, is genuinely a caring guy. He genuinely loves statistics. But there is a piece of this that is incomprehensible when somebody who has so much makes such a grievous choice.
他是一个聪明人，我认为他确实是一个关心他人的家伙。他真心热爱统计学。但当一个拥有那么多的人做出如此严重的错误选择时，这其中有一部分是令人费解的。
Canvass organizers say staff and 73 volunteers worked for more than 3,600 hours, including knocking on doors and talking to over 400 voters for the fake study. Since all this went down last year, Michael LaCour still has not admitted to fabricating data in public or in private with the colleagues of his that I've spoken to. He declined my invitation to come on the radio this week and talk about this. He declined to say whether the data was real or fake.
拉票组织者说，工作人员和73名志愿者为这项假研究工作了超过3600小时，包括敲门并与400多名选民交谈。自去年这一切发生以来，迈克尔·拉库尔仍然没有公开或私下向我交谈过的他的同事承认捏造数据。他拒绝了我本周邀请他上广播谈论此事的邀请。他拒绝说明数据是真实的还是虚假的。
The one chink in this position came last month, when out of the blue he texted Dave Fleischer. "Hi Dave. If you're willing, I'd like to meet with you face to face. To apologize." Dave told me he hasn't been able to bring himself to respond just yet. He's not ready.
在这个立场上的唯一裂缝出现在上个月，当时他突然给戴夫·弗莱彻发了短信。“嗨，戴夫。如果你愿意的话，我想和你面对面谈谈。道歉。”戴夫告诉我，他至今还没能让自己回复。他还没准备好。
Yeah, so what we've done so far is the Miami work. I think that's what we're ready to show you some of the early sneak peek into. I think you're the first person outside of the study--
是的，所以到目前为止我们已经完成了迈阿密的工作。我想那就是我们准备向你展示一些初步预览的东西。我想你是研究之外的第一个人——
That's David Broockman, one of the guys who discovered the fraud in the original study, and the co-author of the new study with real surveys and real data that was published this week in Science magazine. This recording has him talking to me last August, three months after Science retracted the original study.
那是戴维·布鲁克曼，最初那项研究中发现欺诈的人之一，也是本周发表在《科学》杂志上的、有着真实调查和真实数据的这项新研究的合著者。这段录音是他去年八月，即《科学》杂志撤回原始研究三个月后与我的谈话。
It was Broockman and his research partner remember, who discovered LaCour's fraud when they tried to replicate his methods in Miami. Now the Miami data was in, the first part of it anyway.
还记得是布鲁克曼和他的研究伙伴发现了拉库尔的欺诈行为，当时他们试图在迈阿密复制他的方法。现在迈阿密的有数据了，至少是第一部分。
The canvassers in Miami went door to door trying to change voters' attitudes about transgendered people. Miami-Dade County passed an ordinance in 2014 banning discrimination against transgender people. And these canvassers were trying to convince voters that that was a good idea, and to support it if a ballot measure someday tried to strike it down. And they succeeded.
迈阿密的拉票员挨家挨户尝试改变选民对跨性别者的态度。迈阿密-戴德县在2014年通过了一项法令，禁止歧视跨性别者。这些拉票员试图说服选民这是一个好主意，并支持它，如果将来有投票倡议试图废除它的话。他们成功了。
And you see just a huge increase in the acceptance towards transgender people. And overall, what you see is it's basically the largest effect I've ever seen for any political tactic. So much more than phone calls or mail or other forms of canvassing that I've seen. The effect is just huge.
你会看到对跨性别者的接纳程度有巨大的提升。总的来说，你看到的是我见过的任何政治策略中最大的效果。远比我见过的电话、邮件或其他形式的拉票效果好得多。效果就是这么巨大。
In other words, the thing that was so exciting about the discredited study turned out to be true. These canvasses can change people's minds. For real.
换句话说，那项被抹黑研究中令人兴奋的事情被证明是真的。这些拉票活动确实可以改变人们的想法。真的。
Roughly one out of 10 voters changed their attitudes about transgender people. As the study notes, it took from 1998 to 2012-- 14 years-- for the country as a whole to have a comparable change in its attitudes towards gay people. It only took the canvassers 20 minutes or less to do this for trans people. Broockman said the only political tactic that has ever been shown to be more effective than this in affecting attitudes is personally meeting somebody who's running for office, which of course, is a very different kind of thing.
大约十分之一的选民改变了他们对跨性别者的态度。正如研究指出的，国家整体对同性恋者的态度发生相当程度的改变花费了1998年到2012年——14年的时间。拉票员只用了20分钟或更短的时间就为跨性别者做到了这一点。布鲁克曼说，唯一被证明在影响态度方面比这更有效的政治策略是亲自见到竞选公职的人，这当然是一种非常不同的事情。
More impressive is that the effect appears to last, that you basically see the exact same pattern of results six weeks later. We're going to start measuring again at, I think we decided three months and six months. So who knows if these will continue to last into the future?
更令人印象深刻的是，这种效果似乎会持续，你基本上在六周后看到了完全相同的模式结果。我想我们决定在三个月和六个月时再次开始测量。所以谁知道这些是否会持续到未来呢？
They did. Three months later, attitudes stayed changed. Again, same as the discredited study.
确实持续了。三个月后，态度保持改变。同样，和那项被抹黑的研究一样。
But where it gets really interesting is the stuff that the new guys found that is different from the original study. First difference? Remember how the original study said that only a gay canvasser could convince a voter to support gay marriage? And only a woman who talked about her own abortion could convince a voter to become pro-choice? David Broockman says on these trans issues--
但最有趣的地方在于新团队发现的与原始研究不同的东西。第一个不同点？还记得原始研究说只有同性恋拉票员才能说服选民支持同性婚姻吗？只有谈论自己堕胎经历的女性才能说服选民成为支持堕胎权的人吗？戴维·布鲁克曼说，在这些跨性别议题上——
That's not what we're finding at all. We see that both transgender and non-transgender canvassers are effective, and they're similarly effective.
那根本不是我们发现的情况。我们看到跨性别和非跨性别拉票员都很有效，而且他们的效果相似。
Which is a profoundly different finding from the original discredited study. The original study seemed to say that it was meeting somebody, relating to a gay person or a trans person or whoever that changed people's attitudes. It was empathy that did the trick. But this new study says it's something else entirely.
这是一个与最初被抹黑的研究极其不同的发现。原始研究似乎说，是遇见某人、与同性恋者或跨性别者或任何人产生关联改变了人们的态度。是同理心起了作用。但这项新研究说那是其他完全不同的东西。
Really what's happening here is it's listening and asking questions to voters to get them to say the words and to get them to do the mental work to think through how the experiences they have had are relevant to this issue.
这里真正发生的是倾听并向选民提问，让他们说出那些话，并进行脑力劳动，思考他们拥有的经历与这个问题有何关联。
In other words, there's this ideal of well, if you just met a gay person--
换句话说，有一种理想，好吧，如果你只是遇见了一个同性恋者——
That's right.
那是对的。
Then you'd have this feeling. You're saying nah, that's not it.
那么你就会有这种感觉。你说，不，不是那样的。
The idea is that if the words come out of your own mouth, it's much more meaningful to you than if they come out of somebody else's mouth.
想法是，如果这些话出自你自己的口，它对你来说比出自别人的口要有意义得多。
That's so funny, 'cause like, who do you believe? Oh, I believe myself.
这太搞笑了，因为，你相信谁？哦，我相信我自己。
Exactly. So it's not that this isn't common sense. But it's also not what any campaigns do.
完全正确。所以这并不是说这不是常识。但这也并非任何竞选活动所做的。
Broockman and his co-author have also been working on a study of the abortion canvasses organized by the Los Angeles LGBT Center. And here's another difference from the original discredited research done by Michael LaCour. Broockman has found the abortion canvasses failed. They didn't actually convince people.
布鲁克曼和他的合著者也一直在研究洛杉矶LGBT中心组织的堕胎拉票活动。这里是与迈克尔·拉库尔做的最初那项被抹黑的研究的另一个区别。布鲁克曼发现堕胎拉票活动失败了。他们并没有真正说服任何人。
Zero.
零。
No effect.
没有效果。
No effect for anybody.
对任何人都没有效果。
No effect for anyone.
Right.
对。
How do you explain that this worked with the trans issue, but it didn't work with the abortion issue?
你如何解释这对跨性别议题有效，但对堕胎议题无效？
Well, I think there's a lot of possibilities. One possibility is that trans issues are so new, whereas abortion is so ingrained that it was just easier. Like--
嗯，我认为有很多可能性。一种可能是跨性别议题太新了，而堕胎是根深蒂固的，所以更容易。就像——
In other words, people haven't really formed very firm opinions about trans issues--
换句话说，人们还没有真正就跨性别议题形成非常坚定的观点——
Exactly.
完全正确。
Whereas everybody knows where they stand. Every adult knows whether they're for or against abortion rights.
而每个人都知道他们的立场。每个成年人都知道他们是支持还是反对堕胎权。
Right. So I think that's possible.
对。所以我认为这是可能的。
The other possibility, of course, is that canvass organizers just haven't figured out yet how to talk about abortion at the doorstep in a way that lastingly convinces anyone. We tried very hard, by the way. Somebody actually flew to Los Angeles to locate that nurse that you heard at the beginning of the program to find out if she went back to her old pro-life beliefs after the canvasser walked away from the door. But we couldn't find her.
另一种可能性，当然，是拉票组织者还没有找到在门口以一种能够持续说服任何人的方式谈论堕胎的方法。顺便说一下，我们尝试得非常努力。有人甚至飞往洛杉矶寻找你在节目开头听到的那位护士，看看她在拉票员离开门口后是否回到了她原来反堕胎的信仰。但我们没能找到她。
I will say in videos of the Miami canvass, one thing that's really striking is how malleable people do seem to be on the transgender issues in this way that's very hard to imagine on abortion rights. Sometimes a canvasser has to explain to the voters exactly what transgender means. They have to show videos to be sure that it's understood what it is that they're even talking about. Or take this man, an older voter with a kind face who stands at his doorstep in a sleeveless undershirt telling that same canvasser that you heard at the beginning of the program--
我想说的是，在迈阿密拉票活动的视频中，有一点非常引人注目的是，人们在跨性别议题上看起来确实很易受影响，这在堕胎权上很难想象。有时拉票员必须向选民确切解释跨性别意味着什么。他们必须展示视频以确保对方理解他们到底在谈论什么。或者看这位男士，一位面容和善的老年选民，他站在门口穿着无袖背心，告诉你在节目开头听到的那位拉票员——
There is one thing that disturb me. I don't know if let's say, a man that is a fag using a man's clothes going into ladies bathroom. That I don't really like.
有一件事困扰我。我不知道，如果说，一个男人是个男同性恋，穿着男人的衣服进入女士洗手间。我不喜欢那样。
Mhm. Did you say a man who is a--
嗯。你是说一个男人是——
They talked for a while. He's from Ecuador. Doesn't get out much because he's at home caring for his wife, who has dementia.
他们谈了很久。他来自厄瓜多尔。不怎么出门，因为他在家照顾患有痴呆症的妻子。
Doesn't have many friends. And seems genuinely confused about the difference between trans and gay. The canvasser explains what is what about that to him. She even helpfully informs him--
没有多少朋友。看起来真的对跨性别和同性恋的区别感到困惑。拉票员向他解释了关于那件事的一切。她甚至很有帮助地告诉他——
So we don't usually use the word fag. So--
所以我们通常不会用那个词（对同性恋的蔑称）。所以——
Well, it's--I--
嗯，它是——我——
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
He apologizes. Says that spending all of his time with his wife, maybe he's getting demented too. Forgetting how to talk to people. And by the end, it is just like the researcher Broockman said. The voter is the one reflecting on his experience, drawing new conclusions.
他道歉了。说他把所有时间都用来陪妻子，也许他自己也变得痴呆了。忘了怎么和人交流。到最后，这就像研究员布鲁克曼说的那样。选民自己是在反思他的经历，得出新的结论。
[LAUGHS] So--
（笑）所以——
I'm so glad that I'm talking to a really intelligent person that made me--
我很高兴我正在和一个非常聪明的人交谈，这让我——
It's kind of hard to hear. He's saying, I'm glad to be talking to an intelligent person that made me think about my own background. And that it was very old.
这有点难听清。他说，我很高兴能和一个聪明人交谈，这让我思考我自己的背景。而且那是非常古老的。
Listen, probably I was mistaken.
听着，可能我错了。
OK, one last thing. I guess this is the most obvious question probably that I could ask in this story. And I just want you to know I did ask it. Here's the recording.
好的，最后一件事情。我想这可能是我在这个故事中能问的最明显的问题。我只是想让你知道我确实问了。这是录音。
OK, so there's one study published in Science magazine like a year ago. It says that this works. It was proven to be a fraud. Now you guys are coming out with a study in Science magazine saying that this works. Why should we believe you?
好的，一年前《科学》杂志上发表了一项研究。它说这有效。它被证明是一场骗局。现在你们在《科学》杂志上发表了一项研究说这有效。我们为什么要相信你们？
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
We've thought about this. As silly as it was, we did have one of our old graduate advisors-- Gabriel Lenz at Berkeley-- independently verify and go through that the original raw data collected in the survey platform matched all the stages of the data that we collected, data from the study that we'll then post publicly.
我们考虑过这个问题。尽管这很愚蠢，但我们确实让我们的前任研究生导师之一——伯克利的加布里埃尔·伦茨——独立核实并查阅了调查平台收集的原始原始数据，匹配了我们收集的所有数据阶段，即我们将公开发布的研究中的数据。
He's saying that unlike Michael LaCour, they gave their actual raw information of what all the survey respondents said to somebody else to look at, who also made sure that the numbers in their charts and graphs and analysis match what the actual surveys say. They're posting the original survey data without people's names or identifying information online for anybody to inspect. Science marches on.
他说，不像迈克尔·拉库尔，他们把所有调查受访者说的真实原始信息交给了另一个人去看，那个人也确保了他们图表和分析中的数字与实际调查内容相符。他们正在网上发布原始调查数据，没有人们的姓名或识别信息，供任何人查阅。科学在前进。
Coming up, a stranger tries to make somebody rethink everything in his life over the phone in one hour in one conversation. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下里，一个陌生人试图在一个小时内通过电话让某人重新思考他生活中的一切。那将在芝加哥公共广播电台一分钟后，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Each week on our program of course, we choose some theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, "For your Reconsideration."
当然，每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的不同类型的故事。今天的节目，“重新考虑”。
We have stories today of people going back and rethinking evidence, reconsidering where they've been and what has come before. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, "Hotline Bleak."
今天我们有关于人们回顾并重新思考证据、重新考虑他们曾经历过和以前发生过的事情的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“热线忧郁”。
So here's an example of a guy reconsidering his life in real time on the phone with a complete stranger. The recording comes from Chris Gethard, who's a comedian. He also does a cable TV show. He's been on our program now and then.
这是一个家伙在电话里与一个完全陌生的人实时重新考虑他人生的例子。录音来自克里斯·盖哈德，他是一位喜剧演员。他也做有线电视节目。他偶尔会出现在我们的节目中。
And the recording that I want to play you comes from this new podcast that Chris is doing called Beautiful Stories From Anonymous People. Our editor Joel Lovell is the one who heard it and loved it.
我想让你听的这段录音来自克里斯正在做的这个新播客，叫做“来自匿名人士的美丽故事”。我们的编辑乔尔·洛弗尔是那个听到它并喜欢上它的人。
So the idea for the podcast is pretty simple. Chris is in a studio in New York, and he opens the phone line to one caller, an anonymous person calling in from anywhere for any reason at all.
所以播客的想法很简单。克里斯在纽约的一个录音室里，他打开电话线路给一位呼叫者，一个匿名的人因为任何原因从任何地方打进电话。
The only rules guiding the conversation are it's 60 minutes long and Chris can't hang up. If the caller decides to get off the line before the hour is up, if they get annoyed or mad or tired of Chris, that's totally fine. But Chris, he's in it for the duration.
指导对话的唯一规则是它长达60分钟，克里斯不能挂断。如果呼叫者决定在这一小时结束前离开线路，如果他们感到烦恼、生气或厌倦了克里斯，那完全没问题。但克里斯，他会坚持到底。
In this call you're about to hear, you can feel him at the beginning getting his bearings, so it's a little meandering. And then something changes.
在这段你即将听到的电话中，你可以感觉到他在开始时摸不着头脑，所以谈话有点漫无目的。然后发生了变化。
[BEEP]
（哔）
Hey, this is Gethard. How are you?
嘿，我是盖哈德。你好吗？
Hey, what's up?
嘿，怎么了？
Eh, not much.
呃，没什么。
Just a second. I'm in a weird hallway right now. Am I echoey?
等一下。我现在在一个奇怪的走廊里。我有回声吗？
Ah, no. I think you're pretty good.
啊，没有。我觉得你挺好的。
Awesome.
太好了。
So what are we talking about?
那么我们谈些什么？
I don't know. I'm at work. I just took about a 30-minute break in my car. I walked back in and then yeah, just nobody's here.
我不知道。我在工作。我刚才在车里休息了大约30分钟。我走回来，然后是的，这里没人。
So you're just doing whatever you want.
所以你只是在做任何你想做的事。
I do customer service for accounts payable.
我做应付账款的客户服务。
How is that? How do you like that?
那是怎样的？你喜欢那样吗？
Oh, it's the worst, Chris.
噢，这是最糟糕的，克里斯。
Yeah, it sounds like it. I didn't want to be judgmental, but it sounds awful. [LAUGHS] You're hiding in your car.
是的，听起来是这样。我不想妄下定论，但这听起来糟透了。（笑）你躲在你的车里。
Yeah. It's been a year I've been doing this. I just feel like I've kind of wasted the last year. I feel like I spend a lot of time not doing things.
是的。我已经做了一年了。我只是觉得过去这一年有点浪费了。我觉得我花了很多时间没有做任何事情。
What are the things you're not doing?
你没做的是哪些事情？
I don't-- go to that-- take those improv classes.
我不——去那个——参加那些即兴表演课。
Uh huh.
嗯哼。
Go hang out.
去逛逛。
But even when I say what are the things, you don't quite--
但即使当我问是哪些事情时，你也没有完全——
Yeah, I--
是的，我——
You don't really even know what the things are.
你甚至真的不知道那些事情是什么。
I feel I'm generally uncertain about everything.
我觉得我对一切都普遍感到不确定。
You kind of have a dream to have some dreams.
你有点梦想去拥有一些梦想。
Mhm.
嗯哼。
Man, that's-- I don't want to be judgmental. I'm not trying to be judgmental. I say this with love. That's a--
老兄，那——我不想妄下定论。我不是要妄下定论。我是带着爱说这句话的。那是一个——
No. I know.
不。我知道。
That's a grim place to be.
那是一个阴暗的地方。
This kind of conversation with a sad person who has a vague wish to join an improv class or maybe go to an open mic night but probably won't, this is really familiar terrain for Chris. He hosts a show on cable and he often talks about his own mental health struggles. And he and his staff, they're always concocting ingenious ways to motivate and cheer up depressed people. Specifically, their own depressed fans.
这种与一个有着模糊愿望去参加即兴表演课或可能去参加开放麦之夜但可能不会去的悲伤之人的对话，这对克里斯来说是一个非常熟悉的领域。他在有线电视上主持一个节目，他经常谈论他自己的心理健康斗争。他和他的员工，他们总是想出巧妙的方法来激励和振奋抑郁的人。具体来说，他们自己抑郁的粉丝。
There's this one episode where Chris says, "OK, we're going to generate some footage here for people to revisit if they ever need to feel better." And then Ellie Kemper, that really sunny actress from The Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt comes on. And they just keep bringing out impossibly cute things. There's a basket of bunnies.
有一集克里斯说，“好吧，我们在这里为人们生成一些素材，以便他们如果需要感觉好一点时可以回顾。”然后艾莉·坎普尔，那个来自《我本坚强》的阳光女演员来了。他们只是不断拿出令人难以置信可爱的东西。有一个装满兔子的篮子。
"Oh bunnies!"
“噢，兔子！”
"Oh, look at these little baby bunnies!"
“噢，看这些可爱的小兔子！”
And then a kitten. And then a baby dressed in a tuxedo. And she keeps having these huge spasms of joy.
然后是一只小猫。然后是一个穿着燕尾服的婴儿。她不断有巨大的喜悦痉挛。
"Oh!"
“噢！”
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
All of which is to say this guy on the line saying he's not even sure what his dreams are, for Chris, that's like someone calling Suze Orman to talk about their FICO score.
这一切都是说，这个在电话线上说他甚至不确定自己梦想是什么的家伙，对克里斯来说，这就像有人打电话给苏兹·奥曼谈论他们的FICO分数。
So how do we work on this?
那么我们要如何解决这个问题呢？
I don't know, Chris. I think I've probably been drinking too much, smoking too much weed. I need to be exercising. I should be meditating. I should be going to therapy.
我不知道，克里斯。我想我可能喝得太多，大麻抽得太多了。我需要锻炼。我应该冥想。我应该去治疗。
Feels like this phone call--
感觉这个电话——
Is this becoming therapy?
这正在变成治疗吗？
Well, it feels like this phone call is you taking one of the actions you say you don't usually take.
嗯，感觉这个电话是你正在采取你所说你通常不采取的行动之一。
Mhm.
嗯哼。
So I feel some responsibility to effect permanent change via this phone call.
所以我感到有责任通过这个电话带来永久的改变。
Yeah. That'd be nice. I don't want to put that pressure on you.
是的。那会很好。我不想给你施加压力。
No, I'll step up. I'll do my best.
不，我会挺身而出。我会尽力的。
Yeah.
是的。
What do I gotta do on this phone call? What do I gotta do in the next 49 minutes and 28 seconds? What do I gotta do to get you to never walk back into that office again? What do I gotta do to get you to get back in your car on this phone call and drive away from that office you hate while on this phone call?
我在这个电话里必须做什么？在接下来的49分28秒里我必须做什么？我必须做什么才能让你再也不走回那个办公室？我必须做什么才能让你在这个电话里回到车里，开着车离开那个你讨厌的办公室？
For the next 10 minutes or so, they talk exit strategies. Like "OK, let's start blue skying here. Do you have enough saved up to get out right now and buy yourself a little time to look for something better?" He's got $300 in the bank. So no, not even close.
在接下来的10分钟左右，他们谈论离开策略。比如“好吧，让我们开始在这里构想。你存够钱现在就离开并买点时间寻找更好的东西了吗？”他在银行里有300美元。所以，不，差得远呢。
"All right, well, what else do you want to do?" No clear idea. His current plan is to get free by just being terrible at his job.
“好吧，那你想做点别的什么？”没有明确的想法。他目前的计划是通过在工作中表现糟糕来获得自由。
There was a point-- and it's still kind of ongoing since the summer-- of trying to get fired.
有一个点——从夏天开始一直持续着——试图被解雇。
OK, so actively trying to get fired.
好的，所以积极地尝试被解雇。
And it  just doesn't happen.
但这根本没有发生。
OK, so then--
好的，那么——
Yeah. Actively shirking responsibility.
是的。积极地逃避责任。
You found that, that you--
你发现了，你——
And that makes it--that feels worse.
这让它——感觉更糟。
[LAUGHS] It does. It feels worse. You don't feel like you're getting away with something.
（笑）确实。感觉更糟。你感觉不到你在逃避什么。
It's like, oh--
就像，哦——
You don't feel like you're sticking it to the man. You just--
你感觉不到你在对体制反抗。你只是——
Nothing. You're not holding me to a very high standard.
没什么。你并没有要求我达到很高的标准。
Can I ask how you got here? Where does it start? Not even thinking about the job. Where does it start?
我可以问问你是怎么走到这一步的吗？这是从哪里开始的？甚至不是在想那份工作。这是从哪里开始的？
Where do you come from? How do you grow up? And this is what you're telling me about.
你从哪里来？你怎么长大的？这就是你正在告诉我的。
Yeah. So where do you want me to start?
是的。那么你想让我从哪里开始？
The beginning! We got 40 minutes. We got 39 minutes.
开始！我们有40分钟。我们有39分钟。
The beginning of my life?
我人生的开始？
Yes! I want to hear about the beginning of your life.
是的！我想听听你人生的开始。
Yeah, I was born in Lake Jackson, Texas. The doctor that delivered me, I believe, was Ron Paul.
是的，我出生在德克萨斯州莱克杰克逊。为我接生的医生，我相信，是罗恩·保罗。
What?
什么？
Ron Paul? The Libertarian?
罗恩·保罗？那个自由意志主义者？
Yeah. Rand Paul's father, the--
是的。兰德·保罗的父亲，那个——
Yeah, he was the OB/GYN and the Congressman in the district I'm from.
是的，他是我出身地区的产科医生和国会议员。
I ask you about the beginning of your life and the answer is that you were delivered into the world by rabble-rousing outsider politician Ron Paul.
我问你人生的开始，而答案是你是由那个煽动性的局外政客罗恩·保罗带到这个世界上的。
I'll just add this to that day. When I was born, my mom had been in prison. And they let her out of prison to have me.
我会把这一天添加到那里面。我出生时，我妈妈一直在监狱里。他们放她出狱生下了我。
Wow! Can I ask what your mom was in prison for?
哇！我可以问问你妈妈是因为什么进监狱的吗？
Mostly drugs and the types of things you do to get drugs.
主要是毒品和为了得到毒品而做的那类事情。
Yeah.
是的。
I was raised by my grandparents. Now I didn't know who my dad was until I was 14.
我是由祖父母抚养长大的。我直到14岁才知道我的父亲是谁。
14. OK.
14。好的。
There was kind of a different guy I thought was my dad. Some balding, redheaded redneck. But my dad was the guy my mom was married to before that.
有一个我以为是我父亲的另一个人。某个秃顶、红头发的乡巴佬。但我父亲是我妈妈在那之前嫁给的那个家伙。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
They got married in high school in Montana. Moved down to Texas, got divorced, then hooked up 10 years later at the fair.
他们在蒙大拿州读高中时结婚。搬到德克萨斯州，离婚，然后10年后在集市上又勾搭上了。
At the fair.
在集市上。
Yeah, at the fair. And then that's where I came from. I was a carnival baby.
是的，在集市上。然后我就从那里来了。我是个嘉年华宝宝。
Hold on. You gotta give me permission to laugh at the phrase "carnival baby." 'Cause this is a very personal--
等等。你得给我许可让我笑话“嘉年华宝宝”这个短语。因为这是一个非常私人的——
Oh yeah, of course.
噢是的，当然。
[LAUGHS] Thank you so much. This is a personal story and there's a lot of grim details to it. But you can't use the phrase--
（笑）非常感谢。这是一个私人的故事，有很多阴暗的细节。但你不能使用这个短语——
Yeah.
是的。
"I was a carnival baby" and not expect me to laugh a little bit.
“我是个嘉年华宝宝”，却不指望我笑一点点。
Yeah, no.
是的，不。
Now when you say they hooked up at the fair, do you mean they saw each other at the fair, remembered their old flame, went back to one or the other's house, and had a night of lovemaking to remember the old times? Or are you saying ran into each other at the fair and then behind the [BEEP] Gravitron, you get conceived?
现在当你说他们在集市上勾搭上时，你的意思是他们在集市上看到了对方，想起了旧情，回到其中一人的家里，度过了一个值得纪念的旧时光的爱之夜？还是你在说在集市上碰到了对方，然后在那台（哔）Gravitron（游乐设施）后面，你就被怀上了？
I think it's more the latter.
我觉得更像是后者。
'Cause I don't want to be crass. I'm not trying to be insensitive. But you're telling me, your perception is you were conceived behind a corn dog stand?
因为我不想变得粗鲁。我不是要变得不敏感。但你在告诉我，你的理解是你是在热狗摊后面被怀上的？
Yeah. I imagined in the bathroom. But I don't know.
是的。我想象是在洗手间。但我不知道。
Man, you have had to think hard about the circumstances of your conception more than almost anybody I've ever met.
老兄，你不得不比我见过的几乎任何人都更努力地思考你受孕的环境。
Yeah.
是的。
I should say here that we tracked the caller down and talked to some of his relatives. And everything he says in this conversation-- being delivered by Ron Paul, his mom being in prison, his having been conceived at the fair-- it's all true.
我应该在这里说，我们追踪到了这位呼叫者并与他的一些亲戚谈过。他在这次谈话中所说的一切——由罗恩·保罗接生、他妈妈在监狱里、他在集市上被怀上——都是真的。
So Chris says, what's next? They're at 33 minutes and the clock's ticking and you can start to hear a little urgency in his voice. And the guy walks him through high school and college. And then after college, he moves into a trailer park. And a neighbor there tells him about a job opening at the place where he's calling from now, a company with the almost diabolically generic name Bank Tech, where he spends big swaths of his time hiding out in the hallway or eating yogurt out in his car.
所以克里斯说，接下来是什么？他们聊了33分钟，钟表在滴答作响，你可以开始听到他声音里的一点紧迫感。那个家伙带他走过了高中和大学。然后在大学毕业后，他搬进了一个拖车公园。那里的一位邻居告诉他现在他打电话的地方有一个空缺，一家名字几乎带有恶魔般通用性的公司Bank Tech，他在那里花大把时间躲在走廊里或在车里吃酸奶。
So there's that, I guess, the private yogurt time. But otherwise, it's soul death. Just slow, low wattage depression.
所以有那个，我想，私人酸奶时间。但除此之外，就是灵魂死亡。只是缓慢的、低功率的抑郁。
There's about 10 minutes of that. And then Chris starts to press him. He actually really tries to change the guy's life in the brief time they have left.
大约有10分钟那样。然后克里斯开始对他施压。他实际上真的试图在他们剩下的短暂时间里改变这个家伙的生活。
What makes you happy on a daily basis? What are the moments that wake you up?
什么让你每天感到快乐？什么时刻会唤醒你？
I don't know if I can confidently give you an answer on that. I don't know. I feel like lately it's been go to work, go home, internet, drink, smoke, sleep, repeat.
我不知道我能否自信地给你一个答案。我不知道。我觉得最近就是去工作，回家，互联网，喝酒，抽烟，睡觉，重复。
So we can call this one. Honestly, you're giving up a little bit huh?
所以我们可以把这次称为——老实说，你有点放弃了，是吗？
No, I'm not giving up. Do you feel like I am? Am I shutting down?
不，我没有放弃。你觉得我有吗？我是在封闭自己吗？
I don't know. I mean, I don't know you at all beyond the past 43 minutes of our time together. But I'll say it sounds to me like you fought all the way through college. And then it sounds like after college, sounds like you stopped fighting.
我不知道。我的意思是，除了我们在一起过去的43分钟之外，我一点也不了解你。但我会说，听起来像是在大学里你一直在战斗。然后听起来大学毕业后，听起来你停止战斗了。
That's accurate, I think.
我想那是准确的。
Right?
对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
What do I gotta do here? What do I gotta do? You tell me what I gotta do, 'cause I want to help.
我在这里必须做什么？我必须做什么？你告诉我我必须做什么，因为我想提供帮助。
And we got 13 minutes left. And then the phone gets hung up and I might never speak to you again in our whole lives. And this one I'm going to think about forever.
我们还剩下13分钟。然后电话挂断了，我可能这辈子再也不会和你说话了。关于这个，我会永远挂念的。
Do you have a pep talk? How do I start fighting?
你有激励的话吗？我该如何开始战斗？
I feel like this whole phone call's been the goddamn pep talk!
我觉得整个这个电话就是该死的激励的话！
Yeah. I don't know if you can do more.
是的。我不知道你还能不能做更多。
But I want to so bad. You should be going to see a band or a comedy show every night. You should be staying out late and talking to people every night, 'cause it sounds like you have a job where you could show up and literally go to sleep and no one would care.
但我非常想。你应该每天晚上去看乐队或喜剧表演。你应该每天晚上待到很晚并与人交谈，因为听起来你有一份可以出现并真的去睡觉而没人会在意的工作。
Yeah.
是的。
Sounds like if you--
听起来如果你——
No one would-- or it wouldn't matter.
没人会——或者这无关紧要。
It sounds like if you got four hours of sleep every night 'cause you were out experiencing art and hanging out with people and doing crazy things and just living, you could come into Bank Tech, say hello, lay down under your desk, wake up eight hours later, and do it all again, and there would be no consequences.
听起来如果你每天晚上有四个小时的睡眠，因为你一直在体验艺术、与人交往、做疯狂的事情并且只是生活，你就可以走进Bank Tech，打个招呼，躺在桌子下，八小时后醒来，重新做一遍这一切，并且不会有任何后果。
Yeah.
是的。
Go out every night.
每天晚上出去。
I haven't been-- I haven't been living.
我一直没有——我一直没有生活。
You gotta live!
你必须生活！
I feel like I get off work and I'm like, oh eight hours of sleep.
我觉得我下班了，我就像，噢八小时睡眠。
What is tonight?
今晚是什么？
Yeah.
是的。
Tonight's Monday? I'm just going to ask. My heart is bleeding a little bit. What city are you in?
今晚是周一？我只是要问。我的心有点在流血。你在哪个城市？
I live in Denton. I work in Dallas.
我住在丹顿。我在达拉斯工作。
You're in Denton? Denton has a huge music scene! Denton's like, an arts hub of Texas!
你在丹顿？丹顿有一个巨大的音乐场景！丹顿就像，德克萨斯的艺术中心！
I know!
我知道！
You're in the middle of it all! Go!
你就在它的中心！去吧！
You go see the Marked Men! You go see the Mind Spiders! Even I know the bands that are in Denton, and I live in New York! You go! You live in Denton!
你去看看Marked Men！你去看看Mind Spiders！甚至我知道丹顿的那些乐队，而我住在纽约！你去！你住在丹顿！
Yeah.
是的。
It's full of college people who are beautiful and young and making mistakes! You've got to just go!
它充满了美丽的、年轻的、正在犯错的大学生！你必须去！
I know.
我知道。
There's stuff everywhere!
到处都是东西！
There's no excuse, is there?
没有借口，对吧？
I'm going to wonder forever if you did it!
我会永远想知道你做到了没有！
I should've--
我本应该——
I'm going to wonder forever if you did it. We got seven minutes and I'm not convinced.
我会永远想知道你做到了没有。我们还有七分钟，而我还没被说服。
Oh. I don't know. I'm not convinced either.
噢。我不知道。我也没有被说服。
No! That's not the answer I wanted! I wanted you to say, no this  has effected permanent change!
不！那不是我想要的答案！我想要你说，不，这已经带来了永久的改变！
I've seen enough of my patterns. You'll know!
我已经看到了足够多的我的模式。你会知道的！
Oh god!
噢上帝！
I'll go do it and you'll know.
我会去做，而你会知道的。
How will I know?
我怎么会知道？
Oh, I just--
噢，我只是——
Are you inside? Are you still in that weird hallway?
你在里面吗？你还在那个奇怪的走廊里吗？
No. I'm outside by a tree that I'm pacing around.
不。我在外面，在一棵树旁边，我在那里踱步。
You're by a tree! I need you-- just start screaming. I need you to scream as loud as you can.
你在树旁边！我需要你——只是开始尖叫。我需要你尽你所能大声尖叫。
Break the pattern! Do a thing! That's the first--
打破模式！做一件事！那是第一——
[SCREAMS]
（尖叫）
More!
再多一点！
[SCREAMS]
（尖叫）
[LAUGHS] More!
（笑）再多一点！
[SCREAMS]
（尖叫）
That's a first step. That's what I got. That's the first step. You just started screaming in the middle of the day.
那是第一步。那就是我所得到的。那是第一步。你只是在大白天开始尖叫。
That's the first step?
那是第一步吗？
I think so, man. Did it feel good to scream or just weird?
我想是的，老兄。尖叫感觉好还是只是奇怪？
Yeah, no. It felt good. I'm a very loud person.
是的，不。感觉很好。我是一个非常吵闹的人。
That's good. Great.
那很好。太好了。
[BIRDS SINGING]
（鸟儿歌唱）
Are those birds? Do I hear birds back there?
那是鸟吗？我在后面听到鸟声了吗？
Is that good? Yeah, there are birds around here. Someone pulled up right next to me, or I'd scream. Should I scream anyways?
那是好东西吗？是的，这里周围有鸟。有人停在我旁边，否则我就尖叫了。我应该还是尖叫吗？
You tell me if it would feel good. If it would feel good--
你自己告诉我这会不会感觉好。如果它感觉好——
[SCREAMS] Yeah. I'm 10 minutes away from Dallas Comedy House.
（尖叫）是的。我距离达拉斯喜剧之家只有10分钟路程。
You're killing me. Do they have open mics there?
你快把我笑死了。那里有开放麦吗？
Yeah. Open mics. I've known for months. Open Mics Tuesday. I've got something ready.
是的。开放麦。我已经知道了好几个月了。周二开放麦。我已经准备好了。
You've got an act? You've got an act you want to try?
你有一个表演？你有一个想尝试的表演？
Yeah.
是的。
You're doing it tomorrow.
你明天就要去做。
Yeah.
是的。
You're doing it tomorrow. What time is the open mic?
你明天就要去做。开放麦是什么时候？
I think it's at 7:00 or 8:00.
我想是7点或8点。
You're doing it tomorrow.
你明天就要去做。
Yeah.
是的。
You're going to do it. And here's what's going to happen, is you're going to go and it's going to go terrible. It's your first open mic. It's going to go awful.
你会去做的。这就是将要发生的事情，你会去，并且会非常糟糕。这是你的第一次开放麦。会非常糟糕。
It's not going to be fun. You're not going to be funny and it's going to feel really uncomfortable. But you're gonna feel [BLEEP] alive, man.
那不会很有趣。你不会很有趣，感觉会非常不舒服。但你会感觉（哔）活着，老兄。
Yeah.
是的。
You're going to feel alive. You promise me you do that open mic tomorrow? You promise me?
你会感觉活着。你答应我你明天会去做那个开放麦？你答应我？
Yeah. I'll get it done.
是的。我会把它完成的。
OK, let's seal the promise. Do you  know how we have to seal the promise?
好的，让我们达成承诺。你知道我们必须如何达成承诺吗？
How do we seal it?
我们如何达成它？
Both at the same time. Ready? One, two, three. [SCREAMS]
同时。准备好了吗？一，二，三。（尖叫）
[SCREAMS]
（尖叫）
That was it. He and Chris never talked again.
就是这样。他和克里斯再也没有交谈过。
So I asked the guy did he go to that open mic the next night? Nah, he didn't make it. Right after talking to Chris though, he set a date. March 21st. That's when he'd quit his job and start living.
所以我问那个家伙他第二天晚上去那个开放麦了吗？不，他没去。不过在和克里斯谈话后，他定了一个日期。3月21日。那就是他辞职并开始生活的时间。
But then as the date got close, he told me he tried to do everything he could to undermine his own plan. He wasn't sure why, he just felt like he couldn't go through with it.
但当日期临近时，他告诉我他尝试做一切他能做的事情来破坏他自己的计划。他不确定为什么，他只是觉得他无法完成它。
And then that same week, this conversation went out on Chris's podcast. He had no idea they were going to run it. But he listened to it and he heard himself talk for an hour about all these things he wants to do but never does. And then he did it. He went in to Bank Tech and quit.
然后在同一周，这次谈话在克里斯的播客上播出了。他不知道他们要播出它。但他听了，他听到自己谈论了一个小时所有他想做却从不做的事情。然后他做了。他走进了Bank Tech并辞职了。
Joel Lovell is the editor of our program. The podcast again is called Beautiful Stories From Anonymous People.
乔尔·洛弗尔是我们节目的编辑。那个播客再次重申，叫做“来自匿名人士的美丽故事”。
Act Three, "Kids Look Back." So today we're hearing stories about people reconsidering and reexamining what happened to them in the past. And now with an entire book, I understand, of children doing this? Is that right, Brian?
第三幕，“孩子们回顾过去”。所以今天我们听到关于人们重新考虑和重新审视过去发生事情的故事。而现在我明白，有一整本关于孩子们做这件事的书？那是真的吗，布莱恩？
Yeah.
是的。
I welcome into our studio our senior producer Brian Reed.
我欢迎我们的高级制片人布莱恩·里德来到我们的演播室。
Hi, hi.
嗨，嗨。
Hi.
嗨。
So I have this book here I'd like to share with you. I really enjoy it. It's called Now I Know Better: Kids Tell Kids About Safety.
所以我这里有一本书我想和你分享。我真的很喜欢它。它叫做《现在我知道得更好：孩子们告诉孩子们关于安全的事》。
Now wait a second. You have it right there. You're handing me--
等等。你就在那里拿着它。你正递给我——
Yeah. You want to take a look?
是的。你想看看吗？
Oh, this is a kind of a beat up--
噢，这是一本有点破旧的——
Oh, it's old school. Yeah, I had to find it used on Amazon. Not in circulation anymore. This is a rare copy.
噢，这是老派的。是的，我不得不在亚马逊上买二手货。已经不再发行了。这是一个珍稀版本。
OK.
好的。
So the premise of this is that it's kids telling other kids about safety. By telling war stories that they've been through, essentially. [LAUGHS]
所以这个的前提是孩子们告诉其他孩子关于安全的事。本质上，是通过讲述他们经历过的战争故事。（笑）
So is every story in this book a kid being like, oh I did this dumb ass thing, now I know better, don't do what I did?
所以这本书里的每一个故事都是一个孩子说，噢，我做了这件蠢事，现在我知道得更好，别做我做过的事吗？
Yeah, precisely. Yeah, that's it.
是的，正是如此。是的，就是那样。
And how do you know about this?
而你是怎么知道这件事的？
So my best friend, Christopher Alesevich, is a contributor, actually. He was 10 years old, I think, when he wrote this about an experience he had when he was five.
所以我的最好的朋友，克里斯托弗·阿列谢维奇，实际上是一名投稿人。他在写这个关于他五岁时经历的时候，我想他才10岁。
So he did some dumb ass thing?
所以他做了一些蠢事？
Basically he was-- [LAUGHS] I guess he was playing in his yard on his swing set. And I remember this swing set. It was there when we were growing up. It's got a fort part to it.
基本上他当时——（笑）我猜他当时在他的院子里玩秋千。我记得这个秋千。我们长大时它就在那里。它有一个堡垒部分。
Mhm.
嗯哼。
This was slightly before I met him, I believe.
这发生在我认识他之前，我相信。
Mhm.
嗯哼。
And he and his friend Michelle, for some reason they got it in their mind that it would be cool to make some kind of wall around this fort by wrapping string all the way around the fort many, many times. And at some point, they decided OK, it's time to cut the string off. So Michelle asked him to get some scissors.
他和他的朋友米歇尔，出于某种原因，他们脑子里想到如果能通过在那堡垒周围缠绕绳子多次，围出一个堡垒的墙会很酷。而在某个时刻，他们决定好的，是时候切断绳子了。所以米歇尔让他去拿剪刀。
Christopher knew where the scissors were. They were in the drawer in the kitchen somewhere. So he ran inside, he got the scissors, he brought them out.
克里斯托弗知道剪刀在哪里。它们在厨房的某个抽屉里。所以他跑进去，他拿到了剪刀，他把它们带了出来。
Oh no. I feel-- now that scissors have entered the scene, now I feel worried.
噢不。我觉得——现在剪刀进入了现场，现在我觉得担心。
[LAUGHS] Yes. And you should.
（笑）是的。你应该担心。
So then Michelle began cutting some of the string. And Christopher, to hear him tell it, basically wanted to get a closer look. And she cut towards his eye, and the scissors went into his left eye.
所以米歇尔开始切一些绳子。而克里斯托弗，听他讲述，基本上想看个仔细。她向他的眼睛切去，剪刀刺进了他的左眼。
[WHISPERS] Oh my god!
（耳语）噢我的上帝！
Just right in there.
就在那里。
Poor kid.
可怜的孩子。
He says he actually didn't really feel pain, amazingly. But he did know something was wrong. There was fluid coming down out of his eye. Anyway, he needed very serious eye surgery. He was in the hospital for days.
他说他实际上并没有真正感到疼痛，令人惊讶。但他确实知道有什么不对劲。液体从他的眼睛里流出来。不管怎样，他需要非常严重的眼部手术。他在医院待了几天。
So the thing about his story and about so many of these stories that I really love is one, the tone of them. [LAUGHS] They were written-- just imagine a five-year-old or an eight-year-old writing a war story. Just kind of telling it. Like, imagine them sitting in a bar like sidled up with like whiskey and they're a 10-year-old talking about the time they had scissors shoved into their eye.
所以关于他的故事以及关于我真的很喜欢的这么多这些故事，一点是它们的语气。（笑）它们是被写的——试想一个五岁或八岁的小孩在写战争故事。只是在讲述它。就像，想象他们坐在酒吧里，像喝着威士忌，而他们是一个10岁的小孩谈论他们被剪刀刺进眼睛的那次。
So it's not just kids looking back. It's kids looking back with an unnatural seriousness that's being pressed on them by the adults who are writing the book?
所以这不仅是孩子们回顾过去。这是孩子们怀着一种非自然的严肃性在回顾，这种严肃性是由写这本书的大人强加给他们的？
Yeah, I guess so. Yeah, that's what's happening.
是的，我想是这样。是的，这就是正在发生的事情。
Let's hear what it sounds like. Here, read what your friend writes. And read it kind of like a grizzled war vet.
让我们听听那听起来是什么样子。这里，读一下你的朋友写的。读得就像一个满头灰发的老兵。
OK. (GRAVELY) "The scissors jerked back and poked me right in the eye. I don't remember much of what followed, except that my mom and dad took me to St. Vincent Hospital where Dr. Mark Steckel did surgery on my eye. I learned not to put my eyes near any sharp objects. And I would advise you to do the same."
好的。（严肃地）“剪刀猛地回来，正好戳中了我的眼睛。我不记得随后发生了什么，除了我的妈妈和爸爸把我带到了圣文森特医院，马克·斯特克尔医生在那里对我进行了手术。我学会了不把眼睛靠近任何尖锐的物体。我也建议你这样做。”
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
"Christopher Alesevich, age 10."
“克里斯托弗·阿列谢维奇，10岁。”
So the other thing that I wanted to share with you that I find entertaining about these is the advice and the lesson of so many of these is so specific that I find it incredibly, incredibly humorous, OK. [LAUGHS]
所以我想和你分享的关于这些我发现有趣的另一件事是，它们的建议和教训是如此具体，以至于我觉得非常、非常幽默，好的。（笑）
And even when I remember talking to Chris about it, the lesson of this story was don't lean into scissors that are cutting a particularly taut piece of string because you could get poked in the eye.
即使我记得和克里斯谈论这件事时，这个故事的教训是不要靠向正在切割特别紧的绳子的剪刀，因为你可能会被戳伤眼睛。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
That's what he took away from the story. [LAUGHS]
那就是他从故事中学到的。（笑）
And so they're all like that?
所以它们都是那样的吗？
A lot of them are. Can I read you this one?
很多是那样。我可以读给你听这一个吗？
Sure.
当然。
So this one is in the chapter called-- the chapters are amazing, by the way. There's many, many chapters.
所以这个是在名为的章节里——顺便说一句，这些章节太神奇了。有许多许多章节。
Amazing like what? Like what are the different chapters? What are they--
神奇比如什么？比如不同的章节是什么？它们是——
There's just such a variety. It makes you realize how dangerous of a place the world is. You've got axes, bees, bicycles, burns, camping, cars, cuts, dogs, doors, drinking, electricity, escalator.
有各种各样的。它让你意识到世界是一个多么危险的地方。你有斧头、蜜蜂、自行车、烧伤、露营、汽车、切割、狗、门、喝酒、电、自动扶梯。
That is a lot of dangerous things.
那是很多危险的东西。
All right, this one's my favorite. You want to guess what the name of this chapter is?
好了，这个是我最喜欢的。你想猜猜这个章节的名字是什么吗？
Poison?
毒药？
No.
不。
Wait, hold on. Not staying far enough from the edge of a cliff?
等等，等等。没有离悬崖边缘足够远？
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
Is that a chapter?
那是一个章节吗？
No, sadly. This chapter's called "Nose." Simply.
没有，遗憾的是。这个章节名为“鼻子”。简单地。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
Just straight up "Nose."
只是直接的“鼻子”。
"Nose." [LAUGHS] As in N-O-S-E.
“鼻子”。（笑）就像N-O-S-E。
[LAUGHS] I got it.
（笑）我明白了。
[LAUGHS] All right. The title of this one is "No One is Laughing."
（笑）好了。这个的标题是“没人笑”。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
Dude! [LAUGHS]
老兄！（笑）
[SIGHS] So this one's written by a 12-year-old named Dan Strang. It's actually written in the third person-- which is interesting, it's an interesting take about another child.
（叹气）所以这个是由一个叫丹·斯特朗的12岁小孩写的。它实际上是以第三人称写的——这很有趣，这是一个关于另一个孩子的有趣视角。
"When Karen was three, she was just trying to show off for two other cousins when they were watching TV. She took the leftover kernels from the bottom of the bowl of popcorn and stuck two kernels up her small nostrils. She kept them up there for about a minute and got a couple laughs.
“当凯伦三岁时，她在看电视时只是想向其他两个堂兄妹炫耀。她把碗底剩下的爆米花仁拿来，塞了两个仁进她的小鼻孔里。她把它们留在那里大约一分钟，并赢得了一些笑声。
Then she tried to take them out. She tried so hard her nostrils were as red as blood. In the emergency room, they had no idea how she got them in there. The doctors decided to stick the tweezers up her nose while she was pushing with her index fingers from the top to bottom. Finally, the kernels popped out. I dearly suggest that you never stick popcorn kernels up your nose to be funny, because it's a serious accident."
然后她试图把它们取出来。她尝试得太用力了，以至于她的鼻孔红得像血。在急诊室，他们不知道她是怎么把它们弄进去的。医生决定在她在顶部用食指从上到下按压时，把镊子伸进她的鼻子。最后，仁弹了出来。我亲切地建议你永远不要为了好玩而把爆米花仁塞进鼻子里，因为那是一个严重的事故。”
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
So what do you like about that one so much?
所以你为什么那么喜欢那个？
Again, I just love the specificity of it. Like, if I were to go through that or witness it as an adult, if I were to try and tell someone to watch out, I'd been there, you don't want to go through what I went through, I might say, don't stick foreign objects up your nose of any kind.
再次，我就是喜欢它的具体性。就像，如果我要经历那个或作为成年人目睹它，如果我要试图告诉别人小心，我经历过，你不想经历我所经历的，我可能会说，不要塞任何种类的外来物体进你的鼻子。
Yeah.
是的。
But the lesson that this 12-year-old draws is don't stick popcorn kernels up your nose to be funny.
但这个12岁小孩得出的教训是不要为了好玩而把爆米花仁塞进你的鼻子。
OK. So kids do not generalize. That is what I've learned from this so far.
好的。所以孩子们不概括。这就是我从中学到的。
Yeah, apparently not. And actually, I talked to my friend Christopher about what happened to him. And we were reading through the book together. And his mom actually happened to be there too, 'cause she was visiting him. And she was a first grade teacher for many, many years before she retired.
是的，显然不是。实际上，我和我的朋友克里斯托弗谈过他身上发生的事情。我们正一起读着这本书。而他的妈妈正好也在那里，因为她正在拜访他。她在他退休前做了很多很多年的小学一年级老师。
Oh.
噢。
And she totally confirmed this. She was like, yeah. This is something I dealt with day in, day out.
她完全证实了这一点。她就像，是的。这是我日复一日处理的事情。
And actually, they told me a story that I did not know in all the years I've known him that illustrates this perfectly. There is apparently a sequel to the earlier scissors story.
事实上，他们告诉我一个我认识他这些年里都不知道的故事，完美地说明了这一点。早期的剪刀故事显然有一个续集。
Brian, as his mother, I'd like to interject that he's learned not to put his eyes near sharp things. But he never learned not to put his fingers near sharp things. [LAUGHS]
布莱恩，作为他的母亲，我想插嘴说他学会了不把眼睛靠近尖锐的东西。但他从来没学会不把手指靠近尖锐的东西。（笑）
So I guess two years after he got hospitalized for scissors, he was at school. The school day was ending. He was waiting for the bus with kids in his class.
所以我猜他因剪刀住院两年后，他在学校。学校的一天即将结束。他正在和班里的孩子们等校车。
And somehow he and this girl were playing, and there was a pair of scissors around. He was very insistent that they were safety scissors, like the kind of plasticky, rounded-edge ones or whatever.
不知何故，他和这个女孩在玩耍，附近有一把剪刀。他非常坚持那是安全剪刀，就像那种塑料的、圆头的等等。
Right. Sure.
对。确定。
And somehow they were playing with these. And the question of are these dangerous or not came up.
不知何故他们玩这些。而这些是危险的还是不危险的问题出现了。
I looked at these special scissors, and they were very dull. They had rounded tips, and so they were not sharp, as where my previous lesson was that sharp scissors are dangerous. And so therefore, not-sharp scissors are not dangerous.
我看了这些特殊的剪刀，它们非常钝。它们有圆形的尖端，所以它们不尖锐，正如我之前的教训是尖锐的剪刀是危险的。因此，不尖锐的剪刀是不危险的。
How old were you?
你当时多大？
So this was second grade. I must have been--
所以这是二年级。我一定——
You were probably seven. But you're a January birthday, so--
你可能七岁。但你是1月的生日，所以——
So not only was I so sure that scissors that didn't look sharp were not dangerous, but then I had to prove to another person my knowledge of this matter and to show off that hey, you're wrong. These scissors are not dangerous.
所以我不但那么确定看起来不尖锐的剪刀是不危险的，而且我还必须向另一个人证明我对此事的了解，并炫耀嘿，你错了。这些剪刀不危险。
It's amazing that the very serious lesson you'd been taught by being hospitalized a couple years earlier, the lesson you'd been taught to specifically watch yourself around scissors was the thing that inspired you to be extra braggadocious--
令人惊奇的是，通过几年前住院你被教导的非常严肃的教训，你被教导要特别注意剪刀的教训，正是激发你变得额外狂妄——
Confident. That's right.
自信。就是那样。
--and careless around scissors.
——和在剪刀周围粗心大意的东西。
Yes. Yes.
是的。是的。
So what I did, I stuck out my hand and my finger, and I was like, here cut. It's not going to cut.
所以我做了什么，我伸出了我的手和手指，我就像，来剪。它不会剪断的。
[LAUGHS] God.
（笑）上帝。
Lo and behold, it cut my finger. I was like, "oh, crap!"
结果，它剪断了我的手指。我就像，“噢，糟了！”
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
So I guess his parents had to get called by the principal. He couldn't go home on the bus 'cause he was bleeding quite profusely. Again, his parents had to be told, "Christopher has had an incident with scissors." [LAUGHS]
所以我猜他的父母不得不被校长叫来。他不能坐校车回家，因为他在大量流血。再次，他的父母不得不被告知，“克里斯托弗又发生了一起剪刀事件。”（笑）
He was fine. But you know.
他没事。但你知道的。
So what was the lesson of that accident?
所以那次事故的教训是什么？
So the lesson of that accident is that all scissors are sharp, regardless of whether they look sharp or not.
所以那次事故的教训是所有的剪刀都是尖锐的，无论它们看起来尖锐还是不尖锐。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
And actually I did internalize that lesson. And I'd like to point out, there has not been a third scissors incident.
事实上我确实内化了那个教训。我想指出，没有发生第三次剪刀事件。
And a good 25 years have gone by.
而且过去了整整25年。
Mhm.
嗯哼。
Yeah. Lesson learned there.
是的。在那里学到了教训。
Brian Reed, thank you very much.
布莱恩·里德，非常感谢你。
Of course. Any time.
当然。随时。
Always a fine report. Brian Reed is the senior producer of our program.
总是很好的报告。布莱恩·里德是我们节目的高级制片人。
Our program was produced today by Stephanie Foo, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our editor is Joel Lovell. Julie Snyder's our editorial consultant. Our technical director is Matt Tierney.
我们的节目今天由斯蒂芬妮·福、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德鲁明、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克制作。我们的高级制片人是布莱恩·里德。我们的编辑是乔尔·洛弗尔。朱莉·斯奈德是我们的编辑顾问。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼。
Production help from Lyra Smith. Special thanks today to Shane Fletcher. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
制作帮助来自莱拉·史密斯。今天特别感谢肖恩·弗莱彻。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, summer is coming up, and he is so excited for the Tilt-A-Whirl and fried dough and the flying swings.
像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，夏天就要到了，他为倾斜旋转木马、炸面团和飞行秋千感到非常兴奋。
I was a carnival baby.
我是个嘉年华宝宝。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》的更多故事。